imagínate que me tomo a un vector me voy
a tomar al vector llamado a este va a
ser mi vector y voy a decir que este
vector es el vector 2,1 así que lo voy a
poner justo así 21 y bueno como sabemos
que es el vector am lo podemos
representar de una manera visual justo
aquí si yo pongo en el origen mi punto
inicial y después camino 2 hacia el lado
horizontal y uno hacia el lado vertical
llegaré justo aquí entonces mi vector se
vería más o menos así este sería mi
vector 21 ahora lo que quiero ver en
este vídeo es que es lo que va a pasar
si nosotros pensamos en una
multiplicación de una escalar por un
vector es decir de un número por vector
imagínate que yo me tomo tres veces el
vector a déjame ponerlo así tres veces
el vector
y bueno esto no es otra cosa que decir
que me voy a tomar tres veces tres veces
a este vector 2 1 3 que va a multiplicar
al vector 2 1 2 1 ok de lujo y bueno 3
es solamente un número así que cuando
diga que voy a multiplicar por un
escalar realmente me voy a tomar la
multiplicación por un número un número
que multiplica un vector y bueno
recuerda que un vector lo que te está
diciendo es cuánto te estás moviendo en
varias direcciones es decir tenemos una
magnitud pero además tenemos un sentido
vamos hacia acá bien pero cómo podemos
definir la multiplicación de un escalar
de este número que tenemos aquí por un
vector es decir cómo podemos definir la
multiplicación de tres veces este vector
y bueno seguramente lo primero que te
salta a la vista es que podemos
multiplicar este 3 por cada una de las
componentes es decir me quedaría algo
más o menos así tengo en la primera
componente 1
en la segunda componente tengo un 1 y
este 3 va a multiplicar a cada una de
estos componentes 3 que multiplica a 2 y
3 que multiplica a 1 y entonces voy a
obtener también otro vector que es de 2
dimensiones pero ahora voy a obtener el
resultado al vector 6-3 al vector 63
bien pues te voy a encargar que pausa el
vídeo e intentes poner este vector justo
aquí en este plano canciano y te des
cuenta que es lo que está pasando con
este vector y nuestro vector inicial
muy bien una vez que esté suponiendo que
lo hiciste vamos a trabajarlo justo aquí
6-3 es decir me voy a mover 6 1 2 3 4 5
6 de forma horizontal y 3 de forma
vertical 1 2 3 estoy a algo así y si
nosotros nos fijamos en ese vector se va
a ver más o menos algo así es decir ya
tengo aquí mi representación del vector
63 ahora qué es lo que está pasando con
este vector 6-3 a comparación de nuestro
vector inicial del vector 21 bueno pues
lo que podemos pensar es que es lo que
está cambiando y qué es lo que no está
cambiando de este vector original bien
pues lo primero que quiero que te des
cuenta es que no cambiamos de dirección
seguimos justo en la misma dirección y
por lo tanto cuando estamos
multiplicando por una escalar
estamos manteniendo nuestra dirección y
es más déjeme ponerlo aquí esto tiene la
misma dirección
misma
d
lección la misma dirección lo que quiero
que veas es que este vector si cambio en
algo lo que cambió es que este vector
representa tres veces la magnitud del
vector original y bueno eso tiene todo
el sentido lógico del mundo porque
estamos multiplicando por tres es decir
estamos escalando a este vector por el
número 3 este escalar escala a este
vector y eso tiene todo el sentido
lógico y de ahí es de donde viene la
palabra escalar este este número escala
escalar ok escala al vector 21 y por lo
tanto tenemos un nuevo vector que tiene
tres veces la magnitud del vector
original nos estamos tomando tres veces
la magnitud de este vector cuando el que
empezamos bien pero ahora vamos a hacer
algo bastante interesante qué te parece
si nos tomamos a este vector y lo
multiplicamos ahora por un número
negativo imagínate que yo me tomo al
menos uno
aquí al menos uno y bueno este menos uno
que multiplica al vector a que
multiplica el vector a y bueno si
seguimos con la misma convención que
estamos utilizando esto nos quedaría
menos 1 que multiplica la primera
componente es decir menos 2 y menos uno
que multiplica la segunda componente lo
cual sería menos 1 entonces llegamos a
un nuevo vector de dos dimensiones que
es el vector menos 2 coma menos 1 ahora
qué te parece si lo ponemos aquí en este
plano cárcel no bueno al menos dos menos
uno es caminar de manera horizontal
hacia la izquierda 2 1 2 y caminar de
manera vertical hacia abajo 1 estamos
justo aquí ok y ahora dibujamos el
vector justo aquí
qué pasó con este nuevo vector bueno
pues ahora lo que quiero que te des
cuenta es que cambiamos de dirección la
magnitud la mantenemos igual tenemos la
misma magnitud pero ahora cambiamos la
dirección de hecho a un sentido
completamente opuesto ahora vamos hacia
el otro lado y eso tiene todo él
lógico del mundo cuando multiplicó por
un número negativo estamos cambiando de
dirección a la dirección completamente
opuesta y de hecho esto te lo puedes ver
cuando nosotros teníamos una recta
numérica por ejemplo si teníamos en la
recta numérica al número 5 y después lo
multiplicamos por menos 1 nos da al
menos 5 es decir vamos justo en la
dirección contraria si pensamos a partir
del 0 nos estamos moviendo justo en la
dirección opuesta estamos cinco unidades
antes del cero y bueno ya con esto
entonces ahora te puedes imaginar qué es
lo que va a pasar si yo me tomo por
ejemplo menos 2 y lo multiplicó por
nuestro vector original nuestro vector a
21 y bueno te voy a encargar que pausa
es justo ahorita el vídeo e intentes
resolverlo por ti mismo qué va a pasar
con este nuevo vector hacia dónde va a
apuntar y cuál va a ser su magnitud muy
bien una vez que ya estoy pensando que
pausa este el vídeo vamos a resolverlo
esto es lo mismo que
menos dos que multiplicados lo cual es
menos 4 y después hay que multiplicar
este menos 2 por la otra coordenada
menos 2 por 1 es menos 2 ok ya tenemos
un nuevo vector al menos cuatro menos
dos así que vamos a ver lo justo a quién
es el plano cartesiano y si empezamos en
el origen no forzosamente tenemos que
empezar en el origen pero si empezamos
en el origen se vería más o menos así a
1 2 3 4 hacia la izquierda y 12 hacia
abajo estamos justo aquí y entonces este
nuevo vector se va a ver justo de esta
manera tenemos un vector que se va a ver
de esta manera bien pues recordemos a
nuestro vector original nuestro sector
original y déjame ponerlo aquí am se
veía más o menos si éste es mi vector
con el que empezamos ok y ahora este
nuevo vector como se ve y recuerda que
no forzosamente tenemos que empezar en
el origen por lo tanto lo estoy
dibujando justo aquí y en otro imagínate
que lo dibujo justo aquí entonces camino
a que son 2
4 y 2 para abajo son para cada ambiente
se vería más o menos así se ve así mi
otro vector menos 2 veces
y bueno cuáles son las diferencias entre
este vector y este vector lo primero que
quiero que te des cuenta es que
cambiamos de dirección de hecho
cambiamos de dirección completamente
contraria tenemos la dirección opuesta
pero no sólo eso también cambio nuestra
magnitud ahora nuestra magnitud es el
doble es decir es dos veces la magnitud
original así que si comparamos estos dos
vectores cambiamos tanto en dirección en
una dirección completamente opuesta como
de magnitud la magnitud se duplicó